one
[Music]
[Music]
assalamualaikum ladies and gentlemen
before we go in quick disclaimer this
iceland trip that you're about to see
another did we have a professional setup
back then
did we have the podcast back then
no so the clips that you guys are about
to see are going to be in vertical
format because they're usually going to
be from my snapchat memories or just
iphone videos that i took
for the story
so
understand that trips that we do go on
in the future are gonna be proper
and professional i was going through uh
you know a lot of uh dms that i'm
getting and people are like when's the
iceland vlog dropping bro
you want to talk about that a little bit
was that your first real vacay or what
that was
my first time going overseas
but uh i've been to dominican republic
and other places but overseas that was
the first time
um
yeah and that was definitely my first
time in uh in iceland i'm sure it was
yours too
so what you think bro going before you
before we even embarked on this journey
to go to iceland
what did you have in mind i just thought
to myself this is gonna be like a
vacation type deal
we're not just
just kind of see it
but wallahi was so much more bro
so much more and i wasn't even muslim at
the time i'm doing that wrong
humdillah did you think it was going to
be as cold as it was
oh no
i knew it was going to be cool but
i don't know it was going to be that
cool i mean i should have expected it
because ice
land
so
was iceland generally the coldest place
that you've been to
i think so i mean i've been to chicago
but i think iceland was definitely
colder than chicago um
way cooler so
yeah
yeah for sure for sure yeah what was
your favorite part bro when we got there
permissibly bro you know it was a giant
thing you know so
it was definitely a giant thing that's
why i'm like trying to think okay what
can i say permissibly
i say the beauty of it you know because
it's like when you travel is different i
don't know what it is but when you
travel it's like there's just a
different vibe
you feel different you think differently
and just everything is different and
to be in a different land and to see the
different creations you know like i
didn't even look at it like that but
seeing the waterfalls and then
seeing the uh the glaciers and
on the beach
and the black sand beaches
[Music]
like seeing this of it
i don't i can't even explain what it did
but if i would look back now it's like
it definitely began to open me up
in one way shape or form
you know so how about for you bro
bro one of the most memorable things for
me in the trip i wish i wasn't saying it
but i'mma say it because it happened
bro we literally got stuck in the snow
oh yeah
on a mountain and we had to have a tow
truck come and literally yank us out of
there bro
not even a scratch
[Music]
we had not only were we were stuck in
the ice in the snow my bed but we had
like this side railing like right here
next to us
i don't know and like when they were
trying to pull us out like the the
rental car was about to like
slide right into that rib
bro you think you're what i'm thinking
take off
do you want to tell the viewers about uh
what lamborghini we were driving
nah
bro
and and don't lie bro i kept that trip
budget i kept distributing hello budget
bro i think flights were like 500 to 600
um
you know airbnb
and accommodations were all you know
very low key
so very you know humble so the
the car the car rental i think it was
like 300 or 400 for like over a week i
think it was like nine days
and i believe
it was it was it was a very small car
honestly i can't even remember what car
it was but it was very like
it was the smallest car that i've ever
seen in my life it was tiny bro
and
you were like you were pretty tall bro
so to have you just chilling in that car
bro it was very out of place just like
right here bro i'm not tall
too tall for that car bro that's all i
know
i got a question for you bro let's
assume you went now
uh and you were muslim
what would you do differently aside from
the obvious like you know your salawat
and praying and all that what what would
be changed about this trip or visit the
masjids there
for sure
um i would pray
at like
different spots out there because it's
just there were so many beautiful spots
i bro the place where
it was the the waterfall remember when
you were like oh bro
i i bet you won't go and do a primal
scream
and i just walked up like there were so
many people i just yelled as loud as i
could
i would have prayed that
i have that clip right now imagine put
it up
you have that i have that bro i'm gonna
put everything bro
oh my god bro i i don't have that
okay now
people that made it this far and they
want to travel they want to go somewhere
very different right if they're
considering iceland would you recommend
them to go to iceland bro
i think iceland was dope i really like
the vibe and the feel of it um even as a
normal song
i want to revisit it now we should
revisit it as muslims bro
just like really see like the difference
you know what i'm saying
but uh in terms of traveling man like
listen a lot of creations are everywhere
and if you travel like
it will show you
and allah says in the quran in surah
hajj
where have they not traveled the land
and seen what happened before them and
then it's like indeed it is not the eyes
that are blind but it's the heart
i agree bro that's that's literally why
after as soon as we got back from
iceland i was literally telling you we
should go back again and at the moment
you were kind of like bro let's go
somewhere else but i'm telling you this
is one of those places that experiencing
in winter like we did bro it's hella
cold i know but seeing it in summer it's
a completely different vibe
they call it the land of fire and ice
and you can't really experience
you know one half of it unless you go in
summer as well so i do think oh we gotta
go summertime is there are there any
places that you really think we should
go with rami now any anything on your
list
we should move to malaysia
not move bro
we should vacate at malaysia
and then move there
i'm done bro i'm done guys let us know
in the comments down below where you
want to see us go inshaallah 2022 we're
going to get a trip in in the summer you
know inshallah god willing if we don't
um definitely sometime later this year
and we're gonna bring romney along too
because now we got t3 and back then we
didn't even have t3m sure do you
remember how long ago the strip was bro
it's like before
bro this trip
was
exactly two years ago
really
yeah bro it feels like it was yesterday
though
or does it feel
longer no
if he was
feels like it was just a few days a few
weeks ago
it's crazy man
yay bro i remember we went to this uh
this thai restaurant there
and uh we were eating some good food bro
and we were literally speaking to one of
the
the it was like a family-owned business
you know and i remember you just
spitting thai with them and i was like
bro how do you know how to speak thai
and you were like bro i'm gonna go to
thailand one day inshaallah
and subhanallah bro
was i was i speaking thai i think i said
just like a few words like
definitely more than i know bro
yeah they thought i was fat bro because
i had the big jacket on so i looked like
pig
oh you you trained i was like yeah and
they're like oh no you too big
i was like what are you talking about
and now like unzip the the hoodie and
they're like oh
they weren't ready for that bro
yeah man
what was your diet like back then bro i
remember you were eating nuts 24 7
you know barely
every time i was like yo it's time to
eat bro this man had his bag of nuts and
dark chocolate bro
you trying to what
at the time i was just i was just kind
of eating
whatever was convenient you know
so like we were driving a lot and i said
remember that
and because we were driving a lot
um i just figured okay well i'll have
like almonds
dark chocolate maybe some fruits or
something and then when it's time to eat
bro you know we bust it down and we
would have like either lamb
or chicken and sweet potatoes stuff like
that you know so it was it was simple
dropping off
mine
all right before we wrap this up
anything else you want to say bro people
should travel
i want to talk about the the time that
in iceland menu we were just taking some
rocks bro and just throwing it on some
ice
and you already know what i'm getting to
bro i hope you have the gopro clip
ready
there are these this family bro this
couple and i remember like they were
just so irritated bro but i was doing it
i don't remember why
but savannah love we didn't even mean
any harm or male intent or anything we
were just having fun
and what happened bro
they they tried calling us out telling
us
like
they called us well they called me an
idiot
and um
yeah in front of everyone
and i turned around and i told them i
was like who
who's an
idiot and they they kind of stayed quiet
and then they tried saying something
else
yeah bro the husband tried to fight for
his wife's honor and he was like grow up
buddy
yeah girl grow up buddy
you would like grow up and grow up
like
what what are we doing wrong like we
threw a rock
at a glacier
there's a piece of ice that's already
broken off the main
piece
and it's now floating down this like
a river i guess you could call it that
leads into the ocean that's gonna melt
in the ocean
hmm
i feel like i feel like people people
take life too seriously sometimes bro
this is true
that's very true
i think that's very symbolic and
indicative bro it's like even when you
leave the city the hustle and bustle the
daily stressors and you come to
somewhere off grid and in nature and you
try to become one with nature like in
iceland it's almost like surrounding
liberal they couldn't even turn that
muscle off bro because they're so used
to being in the system
and they're so used to just worrying and
always causing issues out of nothing bro
that when they see someone like just us
just throwing rocks at a glacier bro
which is just having fun bro just
chilling out they just it's almost like
they projected that on to us bro
just how how like stressed out and how
like rigid they are you know what i mean
just think about it bro like
everyone has that kid inside of them
everyone wants to
experience
you know everyone wants to have fun
enjoy themselves and all that and a lot
of people suppress that
and when you suppress that you know you
tend to have issues
and when you suppress that you tend to
look at others who aren't suppressing
that
and it's almost like you want to put
them down because they're not
suppressing it
you know now of course within reason
like you're not going to have some
some ja hill over here like doing some
crazy stuff and then
you know you're all right with that and
you want that but it's more so like
if someone's enjoying themselves like
genuinely enjoying themselves and then
you have this other person
who looks at them and
basically he's putting them down
well that has everything to do with them
and not with the person who's enjoying
themselves within reason
you know i agree bro i definitely had
showed more about them than you bro
that's what it was
glacier patrol on yes
hey
[Music]
let me tell you this bro
genuine question this is how you handled
it but now
after islam
how would you handle that confrontation
differently probably would have handled
it the same except
i wouldn't have had so much ego with it
you know
i definitely had an ego with it when i
responded back to them
um
but yeah for the most part i still would
have confronted them
because it's like
well okay what are we doing
what exactly are we doing that's so bad
here fair enough bro fair enough
all right guys if you made it this far
comment down below
iceland
and until next time let us know other
places you want us to go inshallah we'll
make it happen if it's going to be a lit
trip
and we're gonna get some nice footage
you know connect with allah do our thing
and smash the like button if you made it
this far
until next time bro somalikum
oh come on now bro bro we ain't putting
any listen that's thing between us bro
we're not we're not i'm not putting any
of those clips in that in that video
yeah yeah yeah i'm not making any
reference to that bro you're gonna make
me act up bro
[Music]
my
foreign
[Music]
[Music]